we were smoking Giants in there we was
smoking just American children's Giants
just blowing just huffing huge amounts
of marijuana into our lungs and I'm
talking them horse leg hitters man we
had one boy with us he was so weak he
couldn't even hold up some of the big
Giants we was smoking dude I I remember
I got high one time you know they picked
me up at 8 o'clock I got so high fell
asleep at 8:15 I was unconscious right
but still I was young man and you could
fall you could faint or pass how you
could die when you were young and you
wake back up two hours later and people
were like where you been you're like
I've been dead and like we'll
come on back man you're like I'm back
now you know this is reincarnation past
that jaunt again